what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and everything
relating to the marvel cinematic
universe and today we have some news
about guardians of the galaxy vol 3
coming straight from james gunn himself
in an interview with deadline and some
people aren't going to like what he has
to say as you've probably read from my
title james gunn is saying that this is
the last time that we'll see this group
of guardians of the galaxy and he's also
saying that this is the end for him and
many of the characters so essentially
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 is the
last guardians of the galaxy film that
will get at least in a traditional
matter so it really makes you wonder
about deaths based of what some actors
have said like dave bautista who plays
drax said that this is his last film as
a guardian of the galaxy based off of
things like this it does lead us to
believe that there are going to be
probably many deaths in guardians of the
galaxy's final conclusion and thank you
to manscaped for sponsoring this video
more on them in a bit now don't get too
upset yet because i do believe there is
hope and i do believe there's going to
be somewhat of a spin-off that is going
to keep the guardians going even if it's
not a traditional guardians of the
galaxy but let's break down what james
gunn had to say in this interview let's
talk about who we think will die and
then how a new guardians franchise could
come about and continue on in the mcu
because i would like to think that at
least one of them is going to live and
possibly continue on but check this out
the interview is with deadline and the
title even reads james gunn on end of
guardians of the galaxy franchise and
peacemaker's butterfly secret hero
nation podcast so right in the title it
says end of the guardians franchise and
this is the first line of this article
it's james gunn being quoted saying this
is the end for us the last time people
will see this team of guardians and
deadline says that this is what they
told them about the franchise's
conclusion with the guardians of the
galaxy vol 3. and here's something that
james gunn says that adds even more to
the speculation that many characters
will die he says it's big it's so so big
and dark
and different from what people might be
expecting it to be now we know that the
set for guardians 3 was massive we know
that it was a huge set so we know it's
going to be a pretty crazy and big film
but james gonna sit here saying it's
going to be dark and usually when the
word dark is being used to describe a
movie we think that yeah there's going
to be deaths but he continues on and
talks about the wrap up of the story
that we've been on for the past two
guardians films he says i just want to
be true to the characters the story and
give people the wrap up that they
deserve for the story that's always a
little bit scary i'm doing my best and
he ends with i'm aware that the third
film in most trilogies sucks not always
and that's true typically by the time
you get to the end of a trilogy the last
one isn't that good however we just got
spider-man knowing home which was the
last in a trilogy and by far the best
and guardian seems to be going all out
and marvel studios seems to be getting
behind these directors that want to go
all out so i don't have any doubt that
guardians 3 is going to be fantastic it
just seems like it's going to be pretty
sad because i'm betting that rocket
raccoon is going to die i bet you that
drax is going to die and i'm thinking
that nebula is going to die as well
karen gillen said that when she read the
script entirely for guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 she cried a lot and i think
the person that everyone would cry over
the most dying would be rocket raccoon
we've kind of already seen groot die and
i don't really think that groot can
really die as long as there's just one
little twig left of him so since we know
that fact and since we've kind of
already seen him die before i don't
think it'll be that sad especially since
he is growing up again he's not little
baby groot like before so it's not going
to be that hard to watch but i do
believe that there are very specific
reasons why certain characters will die
and i think a lot of it has to do with
the story and the villain who i believe
to be the high evolutionary he fits
perfectly with the story and james gunn
has really hinted at him being the
villain saying that it's going to be a
very complex and powerful character and
one that not a lot of people know about
and i'll dive into detail but first
thank you to manscaped for sponsoring
this video manscaped is the global brand
for men's grooming and hygiene products
they have the best tools and liquid
formulas for all of your odor zones and
i'm talking all of them guys manscaped
hooked me up with a bunch of stuff from
their all-in-one performance 4.0 package
let's check it out so right away when
you open this you can see that it's got
everything that a man would need for
manscaping including things you wouldn't
think you would need but will actually
love the first thing to note is the
lawnmower 4.0 body trimmer the fourth
generation electric waterproof trimmer
with advanced skin safe technology which
reduces nicks and cuts on the most
sensitive regions of the body it's got
an led light on it so you can see as i
mentioned it's waterproof and it has led
lights to show you how much battery you
have left and it has a wireless charging
dock it also comes with the crop
preserver that you put on after the
shower and the crop reviver that you put
on whenever you need it and manscaped
really does have you covered from head
to toe this also comes with their weed
whacker which is a nose and ear hair
trimmer and for a limited time you can
get all this plus two free gifts the
shed travel bag and the manscaped
anti-chafing boxer briefs go to
manscaped.com today and get 20 off plus
free international shipping plus two
free gifts when you use promo code
cosmic at checkout
so in regards to the high evolutionary
being the villain of guardians 3 i think
it makes a ton of sense and i also think
that they're going to connect that with
rocket raccoon because in the comics the
high evolutionary starts by
experimenting with animals and as we
learned from guardians 1 rocket raccoon
was an experiment and he actually is
exactly what the high evolutionary would
do to dogs he would essentially evolve
them to have pretty much chimpanzee
level intelligence now obviously rocket
raccoon has more intelligence than that
but you get what i'm saying it just
makes perfect sense that the high
evolutionary would have created rocket
when he started experimenting i also
think the high evolutionary is behind
the sovereign and aisha because they
believe themselves to be perfect beings
who continue to try to evolve which is
why they made adam and in the comics the
high evolutionary sort of adopts adam
and he gives him the soul gym so it all
sort of makes sense here because the
sovereign is going to be who is coming
for the guardians and you can bet that
rocket's going to want some type of
revenge against the high evolutionary
and i think he might die to get that
revenge and to defeat the high
evolutionary now this is the one death
that i think everybody really doesn't
want to see but sadly i think it's the
one that we are going to be getting now
as far as nebula is concerned i think
she might sacrifice herself for the only
true family that she has ever had the
guardians obviously thanos wasn't much
of a father to her but she had gamora
and eventually made amends with her now
sadly she's gone but she still has her
guardian's family and she's very
stubborn which is why i think that she
might make the ultimate sacrifice to
save other members of the guardians in
volume 3. now two characters are a
little up in the air on whether or not
they're going to die and those
characters are drax and mantis now i
know i said i believe drax is going to
die but i believe they might throw a
curveball at us for drax he's either
going to die because he's going to seek
out the final revenge for his family or
there could be some sort of a twist
where his wife and daughter are actually
alive how not sure we need to get a
little bit more information about that
story but this could be a pleasant twist
that they throw at us if they throw this
at us there is still the possibility
that drax could die to save his family
or there's the possibility that he could
get his happily ever after dave bautista
did say it's his last film but james
gunn just said that this is the end of
the franchise so it's kind of
everybody's last film i probably am
leaning more towards he'll die but maybe
he'll get his happy ending and mantis
i'm really unsure about because there
isn't necessarily a big reason for her
to die besides helping her family and
protecting the guardians which could
very well happen but i just kind of feel
like she's one of the characters that
will just live now groot like i said can
kind of go either way because he almost
can't die yes he can fully die but i
don't think he will in the mcu so it's
kind of irrelevant because he could just
sacrifice himself like he did in the
first one and come back but it really
comes down to peter and gamora now
gamora isn't the same gamora that we've
known all this time but i don't think
she's going to die because adam
warlock's coming in this movie and they
have a big relationship in the comics
and i don't think adam warlock is just
showing up for one movie i think he's
here for a long time in the mcu so i
think they might explore that and gamora
might be sticking around now as far as
star-lord is concerned he could die it
is a possibility i don't think it'll
happen but it is a possibility what i
would like to see happen is him take on
a new team and perhaps call it something
like the guardians of the universe this
could be a combination of some old
heroes that we've seen before in the mcu
some ravangers and some new people if
adam warlock and gamora get together i
don't think he's gonna want to follow
them around so i think this will be an
entirely new team because people love
the guardians of the galaxy i don't
think the franchise is just going to go
away i think they're going to spin it
off in some way at least i really hope
so because the guardians franchise is
one of the best franchise in the mcu and
i think a lot of people would agree on
that but let me know your thoughts about
all of this in the comments down below
who do you think is going to die in this
final guardians of the galaxy vol 3
franchise film let me know your thoughts
in the comments down below don't forget
to like the video and subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
guardians 3 and mcu news and for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter as always thank you all so
much for watching woof